The writing habits that we taught you in
school are what's stopping you from
writing professionally. And I know this
because I spent 10 years as an English
professor at one of the world's leading
science and tech research universities.
I've read all the textbooks, taught all
the classes, and I'm even guilty of
teaching some of these bad habits
myself. But through these years of
working with academic and professional
writers, I've discovered that your
writing problems usually come down to
just five bad habits that writers pick
up in school. So stick with me for just
a few minutes because you're going to
discover what those habits are and how
to fix them. And you're going to have
clarity on exactly how to use your
writing to communicate more clearly,
think more powerfully, and build a body
of work that attracts serious readers.
And by the way, if you're trying to
improve your non-fiction writing, then
you are going to love my free
newsletter, Writer Science. Link is down
below the like button. So what are these
writing patterns that don't work with
real readers? Well, pick up any textbook
and you're bound to find something like
this. It's the martini glass, a model
that's supposed to teach students how to
organize information in their essays and
reports. Great for teachers, terrible
for readers. The idea is this. Your
paper is supposed to open wide with
background information, definitions,
context, and sweeping general statements
like the question of X has been a chief
concern since time immemorial. From this
general information in the opening, your
text becomes more and more narrow until
ultimately arriving at a specific point
that is a thesis statement. This thesis
is explored, developed, and supported in
the body paragraphs. And in the
conclusion, the aperture opens back up,
moving from narrow to wide
generalizations to finish the paper off.
Who asked for this? Like who did the
poll among the readers who said, "Yes,
this is the kind of writing that we
want." But the dirty secret is that this
model of writing solves a problem for
your teacher, but it fails for real
readers. The problem that it solves for
teachers is grading. Teachers have to
grade dozens of essays at a time, which
is pretty demanding cognitive work, and
each student presents their own set of
writing issues. There are problems
relating to ideas and argumentation and
problems relating to form and structure.
A teacher can't realistically diagnose
and fix all of these problems for dozens
of papers. multiple times per semester.
So, they lay out a template that they
want students to follow. That makes
their job much easier. Grading is no
longer bespoke. It's just a matter of
applying a rubric and assessing whether
the writing corresponds to the given
template. For this reader, that is your
teacher, the martini glass is valuable
because it solves their problem and
makes their job much more streamlined.
But when it comes to real readers, this
type of cookie cutter template causes
two problems. The first problem with the
martini glass model is that it imposes
an arbitrary form onto your ideas from
the top down when the shape of the piece
should actually emerge organically from
the bottom up according to the needs of
the reader, the writer, and the text.
The martini glass model wants you to
move from general to specific. But what
if you're writing about your analysis of
a given scene of a novel or a movie? For
readers who are interested in that kind
of writing, it could be better to open
with a specific depiction of a key
scene, like what happened or who said
what, in order to stage the problem that
your article addresses. Or the same
thing is true of most journalism.
Readers expect you to open with a
specific incident in the lead and then
open that up into major strands of
context. The shape of your article is
not something to be imposed from the top
down. It's something that emerges
spontaneously according to the distinct
needs of the reader, the author, and the
ideas. But the second problem with the
martini glass model is even more
insidious because it works against all
readers and not just specific members of
a particular reading communities. All
readers read when they perceive value.
So unless you're writing fiction for
pure entertainment, reading is an
exchange of value. The reader trades you
their attention and in exchange they
want something in return. That something
is value. Now for your teachers, that
value comes not from your text but from
their salary. They read because they
want to keep getting paid. And if they
didn't read your work, eventually they
would no longer get a paycheck. So
that's their motivation for reading. But
of course, nobody is paying real readers
to read your article. So where does that
value come from? It comes from their
problems. The martini glass model is not
interested in problems. It's interested
in continuity. The martini glass gives
background information and proceeds from
that context. It says here are some
ideas that exist. Oh, and also here's my
idea. So at a structural level, the
martini glass essay is going to use
words like and, furthermore, and also.
Now, by contrast, the language of
problems and instability leans more on
words like but, however, and by
contrast, when real readers are scanning
your text for value, they don't see the
language that signals that value, the
disruption and instability of problems.
They see the language of continuity. So
when you use the martini glass approach,
you're not signaling value, you're
signaling stasis. If you want to signal
value to your readers, then you need to
use the introduction not to trace out
background information and set up
context, but to establish problems and
solutions. And to do that, you need to
use the language of instability. Now,
for the second bad habit that we all
learned in school, if readers are not
resonating with your writing and not
seeing the value of your ideas, it's
probably because you've been taught that
the purpose of writing is
self-expression. Think about it from the
teacher's perspective. Why do we assign
essays? What's the purpose of this
exercise? Well, teachers assign essays,
articles, and reports, writing
assignments, because we want to assess
what's in the students head. So we send
you home with a task such as read a
novel or conduct a science experiment
and then we ask you to write about it so
that we can assess whether you have the
right ideas in your head. Now real
readers are not primarily interested in
what's in your head. What readers are
interested in is what's in their head,
their beliefs, their ideas, their
problems. So the function of expert
writing is not about expressing your
ideas. It's about changing the ideas of
readers. Expert writing begins with what
the reader thinks. It sits on the same
side of the table in them and says,
"Here's an idea that you have and then
it sets up a problem. It says here's
what's wrong with what you think or
here's what's incomplete about it." And
then it sets up the consequence of that
problem. here's the cost that you pay
for thinking that way or here's a
benefit that you're missing out on. That
cost might be practical. That could be
something that causes real pain in the
world or it could be conceptual. So you
might say something like you think X and
that thought is preventing you from
answering a bigger even more important
question which is why. The idea that
writing is just about self-expression is
a very bad meme that actually has been
passed on through the writing community.
Even for those who are writing outside
of the academy, writing gurus often tell
writers to write about whatever you're
interested in. Readers be damned. And I
honestly think this is one of the most
misguided pieces of writing advice for
writers of professional and academic
non-fiction. If you're using your
writing in the real world, that is to
build a personal brand, make an impact
in your field, or simply to attract new
opportunities and grow a following, then
your writing cannot simply be a matter
of expressing your ideas. Because as
valuable as those ideas might be, who's
going to bother to read about them? Now,
to be fair, if you're writing about
whatever it is you're interested in, you
might discover some interesting ideas,
but if you stay there, then your writing
stays self-contained and readers will
not find any value in it. So, that's why
I always teach that there are two
functions of writing, two phases. So, in
the first phase of writing, this advice
about writing for yourself is valid. You
should use writing to write about
whatever you're interested in. Use it to
scratch your own itch, solve your own
problems, and work out the ideas for
yourself. Many writers say something to
the effect of, "I only learned what I
truly think after I wrote about it." And
that flips on its head this whole
paradigm of writing as communication.
Writing is not just about communication.
It's an extension of your thinking. And
that's a good thing. I want to hang on
to that. But if we stop there, then we
alienate our readers. So if that first
phase of expert writing is writer
focused, then the second phase is reader
focused. You don't merely edit the text
that you use to do your thinking because
no amount of line editing or vocabulary
swapping is going to make this kind of a
draft valuable to readers. And once
you've developed some ideas that you'd
like to share with the world, then it's
time to write a completely new draft for
readers. And in this new draft, that's
where you reorganize everything around
that idea. You put the ideas in the
structural locations where readers are
expecting to find them. No, this isn't
about following another template. It's
about understanding the language
patterns that your specific readers use.
So you take a look at other prominent
articles in your field in popular
publications or whatever the genre is
that you're that you're using and you
reproduce those patterns in your own
writing. Now if you stop with phase one
then you stay stuck in writing as
self-expression. You need to use these
two phases together. You use writing
first as an extension of your thinking
and then when you've developed your
ideas, it's time to write a new draft
that's reader focused. All right. So,
for the third bad writing habit that we
pick up from school, do you ever find
yourself wondering whether you should be
using a comma or a semicolon, an N dash
or an M dash? Well, the truth is it
doesn't matter. But school has drilled
it into our heads that the thing that
matters in writing is following writing
rules like this. So, let me give you a
story to show you what goes wrong with
the rules-based approach to writing. So,
I teach at a university here in South
Korea, and of course, all the students
speak Korean. Now, since the Korean War,
there's been a split between North Korea
and South Korea. And North Korea, which
is known as the Hermit Kingdom, is
sealed off from the world. And
linguistically, it's really interesting
to notice the differences between the
North and the South because of its
exposure to international trade and
cultural exchange. The Korean spoken in
South Korea has been influenced by the
world around it. So, there are lone
words from English and German and also
some Sino Korean words from China. And
the language has been evolving as all
languages do, but it really doesn't
resemble the Korean that was spoken
before the Korean War. Yet in North
Korea, they still speak the same Korean
from over 70 years ago. That language
has been sealed off. And they also have
some ethnic pride that motivates them to
keep their language pure and not adopt
any outside loan words. Whoops. I open
with some context, some background
information. Forgive me there. What I do
is I ask my South Korean students to
imagine meeting somebody from North
Korea and talking to them. Now, very
soon after this person starts talking,
they're ears are going to perk up.
Something's wrong here. Like, this
person is speaking the same language, so
there are no grammar mistakes, yet
they're going to be distracted because
they're not using the same kind of
Korean. It's the same at the level of
grammar. And yet, there are language
choices in the patterns of sentence
structure and vocabulary that tip you
off that this person is not in the
group. And what I think this shows is
that language is not just a medium of
communication. It's also social. We use
language to signal our in-group status
to each other. And when someone uses
language that signals outsider status,
it becomes hard to focus on their
message. you get distracted and you pull
away from them. So, we're always
adapting our language to signal our in
or outgroup status. Of course, you talk
to your professor in a different way
than you talk to your friend and you
talk to your friends differently than
you talk to a child. We're always using
language for this dual purpose, to
communicate our ideas and to signal
social information. And that's what's so
harmful about these universal writing
rules. In school, we give you lists of
writing rules like don't begin a
sentence with the word but. You should
use however instead. Don't end a
sentence with a preposition and do not
begin a sentence with hopefully and
never split an infinitive. And these
rules have been drilled into us so
deeply because of the positive and
negative reinforcement that we get
through years of school. Every time you
write something, you were rewarded when
you followed the rules and you were
punished when you broke them. Now your
teachers have this task of giving you a
grade and they need an objective
criteria by which to give you that grade
so that in case anyone protests they can
just point to the objective rubric. But
unlike teachers, real readers are not
assessing whether you can follow all the
rules that were handed down to you from
your grade school grammar class. They
want you to see in your writing a
reflection of the type of the language
that they use. They're using your word
choice and writing patterns to assess
your in-group status. So when you're
writing, it's important to be almost
like an anthropologist, examining the
language patterns that are used and
shared among your target readers and
adapting your message to fit. You need
to adjust the register to fit the
reading community and the purpose of
your text. So if you follow universal
writing rules, then you can't really
adjust your message to fit the right
group. There are no universal writing
rules because there are no universal
readers. So instead of writing rules, I
encourage my clients to focus on writing
tools. You do need an understanding of
the rules of grammar, not as a straight
jacket, but as a set of tools that you
can use to adapt your message to meet
the needs of your specific readers. Now,
if you did any writing in university,
then you probably learned about what's
called the GAP model. Now in that model
we demonstrate the value of our research
by talking about the field and then
finding a niche within that field that's
not been discussed. So you see common
formulas like although much has been
said about X, there is a lacuna in our
understanding about why. Well, let me
show you what's wrong with that model
and why it fails to establish value for
readers. Now I saw this play out
recently with a researcher I was working
with. He was writing about the novelist
Cormack McCarthy who passed away a few
years ago. And this researcher was
putting together a grant proposal so he
could go to the Whitliff Library in
Texas and study the archives that had
recently been acquired. So I asked him,
"What's the value of this research?" And
he said, "Well, nobody's ever explored
these archives before, so I would be one
of the first ones to read through them
and write about them." That's the GAP
model at work. Now granted, there are
probably some hardcore Cormarmac
McCarthy fans out there who would be
interested to read any damn thing on the
topic, but for most readers and
crucially for the people who are handing
out grant funding, that's not valuable.
That's just information. And so the
problem with the gap method is that it
imagines knowledge to be finite. like
this researcher thought that the world
was just a discreet number of pieces of
information and he had just found some
of the missing pieces and he was going
to write about them. So the fact that
nobody had written about them before
that's what made his work valuable in
his mind. But to understand what's wrong
with this, it's helpful to imagine
knowledge in two different ways. So in
one version you could imagine all human
knowledge as finite like a puzzle. So
out there in the world there's a fixed
number of facts and units of information
and our job as researchers and writers
is to go out there and find these
missing pieces of the puzzle. Within
this context of a fixed finite world of
information, new information becomes
automatically valuable just because it's
new. Now by contrast, what if knowledge
wasn't finite like a puzzle but
infinite? Well, in that case, what we're
doing in our research communities is not
gathering missing pieces of the puzzle.
It's developing a model of the world, a
way of representing it to each other
that helps us explain the world and make
predictions about how things will work
out. Whenever those predictions fail or
whenever we find some anomaly that we
can't explain, we need to update our
model. So we let go of some piece of our
model, some belief or axiom that had
been widely accepted by our community
and we update the model with some new
idea. Then we use this new model to make
predictions and so on and so forth. In
that second case, new knowledge is not
valuable just because it's new. It's
only valuable to the extent that it
contributes something useful to this
model. If the new model helps explain an
anomaly or helps us make a prediction
about the future, then it's valuable.
But without that kind of utility, new
information is not valuable. It's just
information. The gap model creates
content that's new but not valuable. It
tells us to find an area of research,
list the major trends, and show how
nobody has ever talked about what you
want to talk about before. That's
supposed to establish value. But since
the advent of AI, your readers are
drowning in information. The last thing
anybody wants is more information. So a
better approach is to identify the
errors in how your specific readers
currently think. What frameworks are
they using to solve problems. Show them
what's wrong with that and then offer
them your ideas in the form of a
solution. Show them why their existing
knowledge or approach imposes a cost on
them and the benefits that they would
adopt if they would adopt your ideas.
Now, if you want to use your writing not
simply to report on the ideas of others,
but to actually generate knowledge
that's both new and valuable, then you
need to beware of this last habit from
school-based writing. Because if you
don't break this habit, then not only
are you just recycling these old stale
ideas, but you create real problems for
your reader. Problems that we call
interference. So in school, writing has
one function, to demonstrate your
understanding to the reader. Your
teacher is reading the text not because
they perceive the value in it, not
because they're actually interested in
it, but because they need to keep their
paycheck. They're hostage. So we learn
to write according to this one function.
Do the work, reflect on it, and then do
the writing. Think first, write later.
But in the real world, if you're writing
something valuable, then you are
contributing something new. You're
thinking thoughts that have never been
thought before. You're working on
pressing problems and coming up with
novel solutions. So that's not simply
communication. You need to first come up
with new ideas before you go about
communicating them. So the first
function of writing is actually for the
writer, not the reader. The writer
begins with a problem, something they
don't fully understand. And then they go
through writing, trying out this
sentence, bringing in this reference,
having this piece talk to that piece,
drawing inferences, making conclusions.
It's all quite iterate, iterative,
iterative, and messy. But that's the
point. It's an extension of your
thinking. If you're writing valuably,
then you don't know the answer. You're
kind of muddling through it all and
sorting it out until eventually there's
a click. You have an epiphany. You
realize something. It's not that you
found a new idea. You've produced a new
idea through your work on a specific
problem. And that's valuable. But the
problem now is that that value is buried
at the end of your text. And when we
just hand this off to our reader, we
miss that second function. Readers do
not want to follow us through all these
blind alleys and misdirection. They want
the value up top. The writer is using
the text to think about the world, but
the reader is using the text to learn
about the world. And when the writer
doesn't reshape their ideas to fit the
reader's experience, the reader's
function of the text, right, the
patterns that the reader brings to the
text, they create interference.
Interference.
School never taught you to separate
these functions because student writing
doesn't need to. Your teachers are
hostage. But in expert writing, these
two functions are in direct conflict.
And this is why revision is critical and
working with an editor can be so
helpful. Like you don't just edit a
draft. You use the draft to do your
thinking and then you start fresh,
putting the key information exactly
where your readers expect to find it.
Editing is not simply a matter of
polishing sentences. It's transforming a
draft that serves the writer into a text
that serves the reader. So, here are the
principles for breaking through these
school-based writing habits. First, lead
with problems, not with background
information. Your introduction should
create instability that readers
recognize as imposing costs on them. So,
use the language of tension and
instability, not continuity and stasis.
Second, locate your problems within your
specific reading communities. Value is a
function of your readers. They're the
ones who decide what's valuable. So
identify the specific community that
you're writing to and think about what
they care about. Your text should
effectively say, "Here's a problem
that's preventing you from achieving X
outcome that you want and here's how my
idea will solve it." Third, your idea is
only valuable if readers perceive the
problem that it solves. Value does not
come from your writing style or your
credentials. It comes from readers
recognizing that that this idea solves a
problem that they're currently bearing
the cost of. Fourth, focus on function,
not form. So, don't follow generic
structures. Ask, "What does this piece
need to do in order for my specific
reader to achieve their goal?" Fifth,
school taught us that writing is about
communication, transmitting what you
already know. But expert writing is
about changing how readers think. And
that requires different functions,
different techniques, and different
measurements of success. But if you want
to ditch the harmful rules-based writing
patterns that you picked up in school,
then you've got to know what to do
instead. So watch this video next
because it's a master class in expert
writing that'll help you get back to
what counts, writing for specific
readers and their problems. So be sure
to go check it out.